I'll give you an example it's built off
of this guy actually about three is a
bit pedestrian so we're gonna ramp it up
a little bit let's go to 17
okay what I want is a general term for
these coefficients the Keith's
coefficient I have a cake one that'll
tell me the K plus 1 1 okay so as
usually is the case if you want to
generalize you build a pattern first
okay so what's this thing equal to if I
were to expand it just like I expanded
these guys okay what would I get first
term I'm going to put in terms of the
coefficients okay I could write one but
I try to generalize here right that's
what binding in NC annotation or these
black notation is useful for plus okay
the next whatever 71 which would be 7 I
know you recognize that now what will be
attached to it one one of two x okay now
I move over one more time and I think
it's probably enough to establish the
pattern
how many lots of 2x right okay okay and
then I'll finish last one 77 2x to the
center
okay now look all I wants the
coefficient all I want is the number out
the front I want to not have to worry
about those X's okay so I'm gonna write
one more light here to tease out the
coefficient to tease out the C okay so I
still got seven zero here I've got seven
one and then I've got two and then X sad
all right put the two on his own here
how many twos do I have I have two of
them two squared right two squared
expert and they want to get to the end
I'll have Seminole ^ 7 person okay now I
can write that's enough to establish the
pattern therefore CK equals what's the
coefficient pop can you see it there
it's yeah Bennett's yeah yeah yeah how
would you ride it let's go to 7ck right
yeah
and then ob2 bit of cake excellent good
now this is the general coefficient I
want to compare these two I want this
the next one to be get in the card one
right now please let's get to this step
this one without saying this now you
don't have to say in this language but
I'm just going to write it in the
shortest language I can okay okay you
can write that out as a sentence if you
bike
it means the cake coefficient is
positive for all values okay that are
positive integers we kind of have to say
that much or you could just use the
symbols
okay it's just noting the restriction
you can't just divide my stuff if you
don't recognize it's not gonna screw
your employees all right now I know what
this is I can express it because this is
the general term okay so watch it looks
a bit monstrous but that's okay it's
seven choose k plus one there that's
what's on top right x ^ okay fun good
that was it huh and then I've just got
this guy on one that's greater than one
okay I've run in outer space
now you have a look at this we have been
practicing with our factorial notation
and with our NCI notation we know what
it means so we're going to need to
expand so this unroll some of it if you
like so that we can start to simplify it
out and turn it into less of a bit of a
dog's breakfast okay seven choose K plus
1 just after this guy what is that equal
to do you remember what the binomial
theorem and told us the definition of
this was the start of the seven
factorial over its K plus 1 factorial
now there's another factor over here but
what is it anyway this minus this right
this minus this so that looks to me like
6 minus K all right that toriel okay
that's what's on the top on this to the
power of k plus 1 I could leave it like
that but just to make a little more
obvious I want to cancel with down the
bottom right so the difference between
that is just a factor of 2 that's that
is ^ k prescribed you can't end with
that cool all right
denominator actually it's not as bad
because what you've got there is 7
factorial on K factorial 7 minus K
factorial that's just quit it right and
then there's your tooth decay sum
greater than 1 okay let's do some
simplifying just a 10 point what can I
cancel and give her these guys okay what
else can I get rid of okay so these guys
are just the same okay now what's
happening here on the denominator I'm
dividing by a fraction so this guy this
guy I'm going to put it all at the top
UK with that / division means multiply
so I'm gonna get that - okay factorial
there now I'm going to write this I'm
gonna unroll it one step right can you
see why I'm gonna roll
do we sell - K the next one off that
will be six minus K factorial see that
so I'm wrong this a little bit they're
not got this guy just like the 7 minus K
I'm gonna unroll this guy 1 step k plus
1 times 1 ok factorial good excellent
now I can do another round of cancelling
because I've done this right okay cancel
cancel cancel kids vaguer okay so we've
evaluated all that NCR notation we've
gotten rid of all that redundant extra
powers all of this stuff like I can't
really take it anywhere else I just have
to expand it out 14 minus 2k all over
all that's left is K plus 1 okay cool
all right so by the way if you are
looking at this and thinking why on
earth do we put this all together as a
fraction why don't we just deal with in
a separate side the reason is so we
could do all of this canceling business
now that I've done that I am going to
put it back over to the side okay so 14
minus its UK it's greater than K plus 1
I can do that I've already established
one I can do that because I've said that
K is getting closer to do what am I
trying to do now solve for K right
hmm happy with that divide through watch
the inequality what's that
four and a third is that okay all right
now what does this mean what does this
mean
don't forget the K is an integer right
so I'll say but is an integer okay
therefore this is true this where is it
there it is
here's what we study the subsequent
coefficients are going to increase see
this is true for what values obtained
okay
for K is well zero it'll be true one
it'll be true and two and three and okay
so what can I get out of this do you
remember how before we wrote down we
worked on these guys right we wrote down
that maybe because that's how many turns
we've got we've got a few more terms
this time because I raised the power
okay so we're gonna get this mini now
armed with this knowledge I'm did this
knowledge I want us to fill in the
inequalities that go here okay which way
did the inequalities go what's my first
one I mean it'll be less span right cuz
this one's bigger than that and then
it'll be less than again cuz this one is
bigger than that how far do I go hmm
well look at this look at this you can
look at this biggest value that'll tell
you how how far you have to go right
well this biggest value what does this
mean it means when case for should be c5
is greater than c4 right or if I turn
that around the way that I'm actually
interested in see 4 is less than 5
okay so I go less than less than less
than and then it transitions okay so
which one's the biggest coefficient C
bond there is okay he's at the top of
the mountain if you like okay so I would
say sorry I'm just ran out of space but
you would keep going down the greatest
coefficient is okay now c5 I actually
know what C five years because I went to
all the effort of except that I rubbed
it off uh-huh working out what the the
cave coefficient was right so actually
you can help me right I think we said it
was seven so I see 5 which is 7 choose 5
times 2 to the power 5 yeah now from
memory it's 7 it's a 21 is 21 21 times
32 yeah okay 640 672 cool
okay that make sense yeah okay now I
have a secondary part of this question
but I'm not gonna hold your hand through
it at least not yet I want you to have a
go um you know how all of this started
with it started with this guy remember
that okay so what I want you to do is
now I want you to answer the question
again I'm still looking for the greatest
coefficient but I'm looking for in a
particular case I want it when that is
true okay because it's just a function
of X right you can put any value of x in
there that you like sometimes I put in
zero because it makes things flats
neatly close this is going to skew the
Pyramid of coefficients in a different
direction so I want you to see if you
can work out which direction it goes in
what the greatest coefficient which what
is this going to look like and therefore
what number will you end up with